and finally new rule well not a rule but
a big thank you for all the birthday
wishes today from everybody out there I
really appreciate it
but
thank you very much
but birthdays and vacations are over now
and someone has to explain George Santos
I someone has to explain this phenomenon
in case you've been living under a rock
or you live here in California and
you're Rock washed away
George Santos is the newly elected
Republican House member from Long Island
who pinocchioed his way into Congress
and who represents a growing segment of
American society Liars
now if you're sort of hazy on the
details of Santos's life don't worry so
is he
[Applause]
when they film his biography it'll start
with based on a false story
this guy lied about his schooling his
career his sexuality his charity work
what kind of family raises a person like
this we don't know because he lied about
them too
all right
he lies like a goose if he's not
doing it at the very moment he's about
to
it's a man prep school they have no
record of him nor does NYU where he said
he got an MBA or Baruch College where he
falsely claimed to have graduated in the
top 100 of his class and starred on the
volleyball team
I would say you can't make this up
but he just made this up
and it
and it raises a lot of questions
starting with if you're gonna lie why
volleyball
[Laughter]
[Applause]
he also claimed he ran an animal charity
that neutered 3 000 Stray Cats he didn't
but again what a strange thing to brag
about
he literally lied about cutting off
cat's nuts and that takes a lot of balls
foreign
[Applause]
here's the explained part
don't think Santos isn't pioneering
something new in American politics of
course we've seen Liars before but it
was always about tacking from the
extreme to the center of your own party
what Mitt Romney called shaking the
Etch-a-Sketch
but Santos is the first one to realize
that since we are all in our
hermetically sealed media bubbles now
you can pretend to be everything to
voters in both parties
and no one on either side will notice
some of Santos's lies appeal to the far
right far-right Republicans like being
all in as he was on Trump's election
denying or making the white power sign
in the halls of Congress
or claiming he was a Wall Street
wonderkind who made Millions working in
Goldman Sachs which he didn't
or that he was a luxury Yacht broker
which he wasn't
the giveaway here is that Santos's
district is Long Island New York
suburb of Manhattan not as liberal but
almost always went Democratic Biden won
it by eight points so how did a
trump-loving election denying white
nationalist get elected in a
democrat-leaning district
simple he told them what they wanted to
hear too
what are liberals love identity politics
and victimhood so he said he had a brain
tumor
and he was one of the first New Yorkers
hospitalized for covid he said he lost
four co-workers in the famous Pulse
Nightclub shooting in 2016. he's from
Brazil which is overwhelmingly Catholic
but when he ran in New York he said he
was Jewish
and in fact his grandparents fled
Ukraine to escape the Nazis that's right
his Jewish Ukrainian forefathers escaped
the Holocaust by being born Catholic in
Brazil
his immigration policies we must stop
people like me from getting into this
country
[Laughter]
also he claims to be half black
although I doubt that's the half that
wears a blazer with the fleece vest
and he's gay
is since the divorce he divorced the
woman he was married to two weeks before
the campaign started oh yes George knows
where the sweet spots are with Democrats
too he once said I'm very much gay
what does that mean very much gay you
have a blue check mark on Grindr
[Applause]
everybody keeps asking how could a guy
like this get elected I'll tell you how
because no one cares anymore about
substance it's all tribalism the only
thing that matters is is he on our team
is he doing arshtic
Santos is just the first one to realize
you could do both sides stick and get
away with it because people have
completely tuned out anything that
doesn't already fit their narrative
Republicans love a winner and Democrats
love someone whose life story makes you
want to kill yourself
okay
four Republicans George claimed he went
to the Capitol on January 6. yes he
personally attended the Insurrection and
has tweeted hashtags like Dems are
destroying America but that obviously
didn't matter to plenty of Democrats in
his district What mattered is that he's
a brave sad proudly gay half-black
Latino Holocaust victim
foreign
with a brain tumor
vote for him I'm surprised they didn't
have him host the Oscars
yes everyone saw in George Santos what
they wanted to see Republicans are
trump-loving rich prick Democrats saw a
proudly gay person of color and the
proud boy saw a guy who would blow them
after a couple of beers and not tell
anyone